tras una histórica jornada de huelga
general y de marchas masivas en las
calles el Primer Ministro Benjamín
taniajú anunció la paralización temporal
de la Reforma judicial hasta después del
receso de pesaj la Pascua judía esto
implica que el trámite parlamentario se
reanudará en mayo y con fecha límite del
30 de julio en concreto lo que se aplaza
son las últimas el dos lecturas del
proyecto que pretendía Modificar el
comité de selección de jueces dándole
una mayoría al gobierno el resto de los
cambios propuestos Ya habían sido
pospuestos para el próximo ciclo de
sesiones parlamentarios en este plazo
netanyahu dijo que buscará un consenso
una reforma que tenga un apoyo más
amplio de los sectores políticos pero de
ninguna manera Va a renunciar a estos
cambios su discurso en sí no fue tan
conciliador habló de evitar la anarquía
y la insubordinación sobre todo en las
fuerzas armadas y agradeció a sus
seguidores el que convocaron a contra
protestas impulsadas por sectores más
extremistas en favor de la Reforma
judicial dijo que estos manifestantes
salieron de manera espontánea y sin
recibir dinero en una crítica solapada a
los manifestantes contra la reforma
judicial que ya llevan doce semanas en
las calles el discurso también llegó
tras en negociaciones con sus socios de
extrema derecha más reacios a paralizar
los cambios en concreto con suministro
de seguridad y tamar pactó que a cambio
de su apoyo a la paralización de los
cambios se comprometió a impulsar a la
creación de una Guardia nacional que
esté Bajo su poder resta esperar para
saber si este anuncio será suficiente
para calmar la actual crisis
institucional en la que está asumido
Israel para muchos manifestantes ha sido
un punto de no retorno Aunque algunos
líderes opositores como Benny gangs
dijeron que el llamado al diálogo Aunque
tardío es bienvenido